pretty baby
what power tricks are strange bellatrix
lestrange
you may blame her for taking serious
away from us
we definitely do however you can't deny
how epic helena bonham carter was at
bringing voldemort's right-hand woman to
life
what if we told you she wasn't the first
choice for bellatrix
we know it sounds unbelievable but it's
true
she was this close to not being in the
harry potter franchise at all
emma watson is hello
strange
[Music]
helena was only cast after the original
bellatrix couldn't fulfill the role
anymore why
because she was pregnant the catch is
the original bellatrix was supposed to
be played by an actress who we met
later on in the franchise anyway helen
mccrory
also known as narcissa malfoy yup the
lestrange sisters
are even more related than we once
thought helen was ready to delve
headfirst into the wizarding world of
harry potter but
she joked that insurance wouldn't cover
pregnant witches
either way they did love her enough to
bring her back on as bellatrix's sister
so there couldn't have been any hard
feelings getting up at 4am and being on
set for 18 hours a day that's the hard
work
the producers were desperate to find
someone to replace her with such short
notice and reached out to helena with
the part instead
there was no hesitancy on her part i
love
magic i love the whole world i was all
too happy to play a witch
it's no wonder people always say helena
was literally born to play bellatrix
we can't help but feel like this is
another one of those situations where we
can say
everything happens for a reason it's a
big character
to play that's totally unsubtle
while we're grateful we got the
opportunity to experience what helena's
bellatrix looks like
we couldn't help but wonder what helen's
version of the death eater would have
been like
would it have been as dark as evil would
their costumes look the same
one thing's for sure helen's character
would no doubt be completely different
helena is known for some very dark roles
just think about the parts she's played
in movies like alice in wonderland les
mis and corpse bride
that was all channeled into bellatrix's
obnoxiously villainous personality and
according to helena she basically
created the final cut of bellatrix we
all saw
from her personality down to the corset
she begged to wear
i'm definitely milking every moment that
i have
this was because there apparently wasn't
a huge amount on the page
she even had the idea of bellatrix's
rotten teeth because of all the years
she had spent in azkaban
all in all she wanted her version of
bellatrix to be a savage
and it's safe to say she achieved just
that she would get so
deep in character that she once
accidentally hurt matthew lewis on set
her wand went a little too far into his
ear during
this order of the phoenix scene and hit
his eardrum
ouch but also how very bellatrix of her
helena's response to hurting matthew i
think i took my sadism
a bit too literally like we said born to
play this character
it was very liberating for us because we
had a lot of freedom
as amazing of an actor helena is we
can't deny how talented helen
also was her narcissa may have been
low-key and reserved but she was still
able to channel the power and slyness
of a true slytherin and lestrange we're
willing to bet howland's bellatrix would
have been
just as daunting and malicious but
potentially in a more quiet and formal
way
where helena's bellatrix is loud and
like we said
obnoxious stupid help you could have
killed me
helens would have been more silent and
menacing
we're getting chills just thinking about
the possibilities
there's also the matter of how it would
have affected the dynamic on set
take a look at tom felton he was close
to and adored both
women both off and on screen he even had
a mini crush on helena
adorable but if helen had not gotten
pregnant then helena would have never
been a part of the franchise
someone completely different would be
playing narcissa just some food for
thought
she ruled well because she did within
her world and she doesn't anymore and
nobody knows how
this wall is going to turn out
we also wouldn't have gotten the amazing
bond that formed between helen
and helena helen said that by the end of
the franchise they had become
the best of friends or dare we say
sisters
she grew to love narcissa and the
redemption ending they had given her
the only regret she had was not joining
the franchise sooner
the same goes for helena who after all
these years would still reprise her role
as bellatrix in a
heartbeat i'd love to reprise bellatrix
maybe
although that might be a little tough
considering she met her demise
what happened to the resurrection stone
again in the end both these actresses
brought life to the lestrange family
and the franchise would not be the same
without them they made
the perfect pair it's comforting to know
that helen left an everlasting mark on
harry potter fans around the globe
understands loyalty and understands
preservation of life
helena and helen bellatrix and narcissa
with the phenomenal job both these women
did on screen
we can't help thinking that everything
truly happens for a reason
especially when it came to the casting
of these two characters
one thing is for sure we all love to
hate the lestranges
what do you think about how the
filmmakers handled bellatrix's casting